this man was like a uh uh he's like a
walking geico commercial right
scoop there it is scoop there it is
there it is everybody if i'm not
mistaken he's
already in cleveland ohio as part of the
nfl network draft coverage
ian rappaport how are you ian
what's going on rich how are you i am
currently sitting at what we call the
garage set
okay i'm not sitting in my own seat so
it's got like
uh we got a big desk for a lot of people
with a lot of
space in between and then i on the other
side of this thing got a little chair
for myself so i'm sitting probably in
your seat
okay being honest all right keep it warm
keep it warm and that's where i'll be
ready to roll i appreciate that it's
exciting huh the draft
in person like uh this is you don't you
know i we've never taken it for granted
but the fact that uh
you know last year was done remotely and
here we go back at a draft site
you're already feeling what i guess i'll
be feeling once i arrive there middle of
the week
so yeah i mean the draft is always like
you know
people will say to me before free agency
they'll say like oh man aren't you
excited like no i'm not excited for
agency's terrible
i mean it's great when you know you
break big stories but there's so many of
them and like
it's in spring she's like insanity it's
like a carnival
right the draft is my favorite thing
that we do
by far i love it so much and i've always
loved it but i must say
getting here getting to do it in person
again
i'm literally looking at the stage right
now uh the browns are on the clock for
some reason
the screens and boards sure um it's an
amazing thing i'm so excited
ian rappaport already at the draft site
joining us here live on the rich eisen
show the monday
three days until the jacksonville
jaguars
are are going to be put on the clock
let's get to some of the
reports that you've had in the last 24
hours i still can't believe that the
49ers are grinding tape
uh that they made this maneuver without
you know
for sure taking somebody unless mac
jones was that for taking
for sure taking somebody and trey lance
has suddenly
uh you know gotten their attention walk
us through
your report that um that uh the niners
quarterback search
at three overall is down to two
prospects mac jones and trey lance
yeah uh so this is as you mentioned
something i reported last night and i
think something that
people have sort of surmised like i kind
of assumed that
people knew last week but it sounds like
the 49ers kind of really finalized this
probably on friday and it's like all
right
you know they love justin fields but he
is from what i understand not someone
they're considering a three
and then it's mac jones and then it's
trey lance two extremely different
prospects
literally could not be more different um
i don't know that they are
grinding tape right now like i don't i
don't think that's what it is and i know
everyone sort of laughed and got a
got like a you know good little chuckle
out of the fact that the 49ers don't
know
i firmly believe they have not 100
finalized do they have an idea
absolutely
but you know you want to make sure in
your building that if you're going to
draft a franchise quarterback and they
obviously are going to try to
then everyone's on board you want to you
want everyone to be convinced
so i think that is actually what's going
on now is trying to build a consensus in
the building
they've gotten a lot of information on
mac jones they've gotten a lot of
information on trey lance
they've been in touch with the people
training them they've been in touch with
their coaches
um they've watched them do the things
that the 49ers do on the field
there's a lot going on here more than
just
watching tape oh so
why not justin fields what have you
heard about the fact that he's been
eliminated if you will from the
consideration
san francisco yeah i i would say and
this is something that i'm sort of like
having trouble
answering or coming to grips with
because it's not that they don't like
justin fields and what
you know truly i've talked to many many
teams that have justin field
as the number three prospect when it
comes to quarterbacks but a lot of teams
i would say most teams actually
have justin fields as the three so it
doesn't mean he's
falling it just means you know when
you're talking about
kyle shanahan's offense they want
someone to be able to
engineer it and run it like kyle wants
um mac jones has
a beautiful mind as they say he is
extremely smart trail ants extremely
smart
i'm not saying that justin field does
not at all because he had got very good
grades and is also smart
but on the field you know it's all a
projection but we did not see
fields go through his progressions like
the others
that is my best guess as to why not
field but
i don't take this to mean that fields is
falling
it's just probably not going to be with
this particular team
ian rap report here on the rich eisen
show falcons fans you got them all
freaked out
i'll be honest with you uh ian uh with
your report that uh teams are realizing
how
capstrung the falcons uh are and how
julio jones um could be
the talent that uh is a
cap casualty with the falcons in terms
of an acquisition
um walk us through what you reported how
jones teams are calling the falcons for
him
and you know is it possible that the
falcons either
make a move at quarterback and then tell
matt ryan you have a small window of
opportunity still now to be the starter
here but you don't have jones
or or what like what is the plan with
atlanta right now
yeah i would say a quarterback is a
possibility for atlanta
most of the other gm's or coaches that i
speak with
believe the falcons are going with kyle
pitts that doesn't mean it's gonna
happen that is just what
what people believe i am sort of more in
the thought of
quarterback for them just because you
know hopefully you're never up at four
again and like
it's a rare opportunity to get a
franchise quarterback when you're
started quarterback is 35 years old
um but as far as the you know the julio
thing
i'm not sure i fully realize how bad the
falcons cap situation was until like
so i found this out last night and then
i kind of
spent last night verifying and i was
like i'll put it out when i get up this
morning
um and really they are they need to make
some moves
just to sign their drafts like they are
in horrible
shape and i think that julio contract
you know for him
it's a great contract but it's one of
the worst contracts i've ever seen for a
team
it is absolutely brutal hamstrings them
so yes teams are calling they're not
going to give away it's going to have to
be a lot
we're talking about future picks so not
a pick in this coming draft
but it seems for the right price the
falcons will be open to it
um so i think there's a chance it gets
dealt so that's what i was saying is
you know i was talking to the top about
the mechanics of this it can't be like
an nba trade
where you know jones is traded they get
the picks in this year's draft and then
the trade is executed on june 1st
for cap reasons you cannot do that right
cannot do that but they can do
everything else so they can do because
you know theoretically like
god forbid something terrible happens to
julio or he decides to retire or
whatever it is
um you know if something bad happens to
him
what do you do with the trade if if the
picks were already used right
so i think what it is is you would agree
to a trade
you would not execute it but you'd have
all the paperwork from the lead
you would use it do it for next year's
drafting
and then on june 2nd you would execute
the trade and so of course i was like
well how could you do that but then
literally the same thing basically
happened
in january right i mean matthew stafford
and goffsky traded then like
in the middle of march we go oh the
trade's official right right
so that's what we that would be the plan
oh my gosh
so you know it's crazy i i mean i so
like when i found this out last night
it took me a really like a little bit of
time to be like right well hang on like
this really could happen
and it really could happen but you think
that the
falcons are gonna go fourth overall
quarterback
but most of the people that you're
talking to in the league think it's kyle
pitts
and thus to get everyone signed they
might have to get rid of jones and pitts
could be like
the guy that replaces julio instead of
giving matt ryan all the weapons
he needs to actually win in the window
of opportunity has left
yeah and you know i think one thing
that's weird here
is you know again i don't know if julio
is going to get traded but
the value is never quite what people
think right so
you have a 32 year old player who barely
played last year
who's insanely expensive like yes he's
julio jones
but he also has struggled to stay on the
field
um so the value it's hard
it's hard to come up with the right
value you could do it but these are very
difficult trades to imagine
um but yes to answer your question i
think pitts would basically replace
julia ian rappaport joining us from the
nfl network one of the three
draft sets in cleveland ohio right here
on the monday of nfl draft week on the
rich eisen show
and what the falcons do it for ian is so
fascinating not only because of what it
means for the falcons but what it also
means for the rest of the top ten
because if the falcons do take kyle
pitts as you say
most of the evaluators in the nfl and
decision makers in the nfl that you talk
to think that's what they're going to do
that means two quarterbacks still
remaining in first round grade territory
are still remaining on the draft board
from five on down and we're assuming
that bengals don't take one of them at
five so that would be
kind of a bonanza scenario for anybody
that wants to
take one in the top ten as they
currently are sitting right there
and or for anybody to trade in what are
you hearing about what
our colleague tom pelisaro is talking
about with the patriots
knocking on the door of the top ten to
see about trading in what are you
hearing about that possibility yeah
i believe that is accurate um and you
know that
they're always a team to watch uh with
the patriots and one thing we've met
we've seen in free agency
for everything we assumed about bill
belichick we really don't know anything
right like they went on a wild spending
spree in free agency
and that's never the patriots way at all
um
so everyone says you know belichick one
mortgage feature to trade up
are we sure like dave zigler who is
who took over for nicosia as the de
facto gm
um has i think brought a little bit of a
more open-mindedness i would say to new
england
they're considering a lot of things so
could they trade up to
11 could the patriots trade up
for a quarterback and have dave
gettleman for the first time in his life
trade out
all of that is possible according to me
so
what about getting into the top 10
though are are
and in in terms of that i mean this is
all connected
are the carolina panthers really telling
everybody
um i'm hearing it too that they're
they would absolutely take a quarterback
eighth overall
or or okay so that's a yes so
do you believe it or is is is the fact
that they didn't sign
you know pick up sam donald's fifth year
option just yet
sort of like a head fake that if you
want a quarterback that's dropping
uh we might take him at eight so you
better come up here and go get him i
mean is that entire
or or they really mean it like that they
are gonna
get two quarterbacks age 23 and younger
and go for it
that way like for real the answer to
your question rich is
yes to all of your questions the answer
is yes
um yes there's really like one
quarterback my sense
said that fields would be the guy also
because i think he would be there
so they definitely like a quarterback
unless they want everyone to know that
they definitely like quarterback so the
broncos trade
up over them and maybe the broncos trade
up for justin field
so one of those things is true i just
don't know which
and i think that's what's really fun
about the draft and they both could be
true they could like justin fields
enough and would take him except if
someone else gave them an offer they
could refuse to trade up
so um it's still a lot there's a lot of
injury just specifically with the
carolina panthers lost the quarterback
no i i know that you know the owner of
the of the panthers david tepper is from
the world of you know finance and
you know you gotta you gotta spend money
to make money and stuff like that and
i know that you know they didn't give up
the farm for sam darnold but a two four
and a six over two years isn't
you know you you can't just go throwing
those around
you know on a let's on a one-year looksy
you know what i mean
it's that one just doesn't make any
sense to me like so
you you do all that to go get darnold
and you have an introductory press
conference
and then uh you know suddenly we like
trey lance better like you're turning
like suddenly you know uh the kid from
usc is a ucla kid named rosen and they
don't even take a year to do it like
that makes no
sense to me to do all that yeah i would
say
so scott federer the general manager
there came from seattle
and seattle has one of the best
quarterbacks situation just before this
offseason but
i had one of the best quarterback
situations in the nfl with russell
wilson
and to get to russell wilson in the
third round they signed matt flynn
they signed tavares jackson um they
traded for someone charlie whitehurst
maybe
i'm i'm forgetting the time but anyway
they took at least
three swings at quarterback before they
landed on russell wilson i would not be
surprised if carolina did the same thing
so yes they have sam dark are they shed
with tim donnell the quarterback as
definitely their starter i would not say
that
they are going to keep doing things to
make sure they have
options at quarterback until they just
find the right one
so you know whenever people ask about
the price of moving up or the price of
paying a quarterback or whatever it is i
would say the same thing
it really doesn't matter because if you
have your franchise quarterback it's
worth
literally whatever you paid for it and i
would say for the panthers it's worth
whatever they want to give up as long as
they eventually get their guys
before i let you go ian um you know with
all the scoops that you have and then
all the news that keeps breaking about
the draft that's three days away
um it's almost as if that orlando brown
acquisition by kansas city um that
happened
on friday you know happened like three
weeks ago but i know exactly when the
chiefs ravens trade happened because it
was the exact second i said goodbye on
friday's show at three eastern time
so why would the ravens send away a
protector of lamar jackson for
uh essentially what's a second round
pick you know and others what what
what what happened there with the ravens
and the chiefs
um so this it's really a crazy
fascinating situation orlando brown
made a promise to his late father that
he would play left back
and that is what he wants to do and you
know we could talk about left tackles
making more money
true although right tackles make plenty
we can talk about all the different
things
but when you make a promise to your late
father that's hard to trump
right um and orlando brown wanted to
play left back
ronnie stanley is an all-pro and one of
the best tacklers in the nfl
he's coming back and i think everybody
sort of forgets that right like the
ravens didn't trade a left back and they
traded their right tackle
so they traded the right tackle for
basically a second round kick
and i think they think that's something
that's replaceable
and the value is pretty good and if
you're the chiefs and you've got a
blindfold protector protect from homes
so he doesn't have to run around for his
life um
that's a trade that makes sense for
goldberg i really like the move
i thought it was very clever and i sort
of applaud both of them
for having the um what would you say the
stones
yes the deal to a rival
and is it entirely possible that the
chiefs can get eric fisher back too when
he's healthy or
shows that he can actually return i mean
is it possible believe that ship has
failed
okay that ship has sailed um and do we
know
if uh duvernay tardif is gonna come back
to the team after
spending the year in his uh home uh
nation of canada fighting covet 19 on
the front lines
in a montreal hospital is that possible
for what you're hearing too
we think he is um but i would just say
i i don't know it's sort of weird to say
because he was doing something so so so
far more important
um i would say he will have to make sure
his roster spot is secure
you know what i mean like he's an older
guy he's making some money
he hadn't played in the year nothing's
more important than patrick mahomes
even though it's like an awesome feel
good story
i think i still think people have to
make the change
all right before i let you go ian it's
always interesting when the dallas
cowboys are on the clock
uh i know that uh jerry jones is the
only one who really knows
what's going on along with stephen and
he is it's already been established he's
even said it on the show that you never
know what's in his head only until he
says it
we know that that was i think the earl
thomas story i believe from uh a while
ago
um yeah i remember that so let's put it
all together and what do you think the
cowboys are going to do at 10 with his
infatuation jerry's
with kyle pitts what do they do at 10.
on thursday night um
what do you got and i have to run i have
to give a quick answer and run after
this
i i believe they will either stay and
pick
a corner or trade back i think they're
more likely to trade back than not
and if the team let's say the patriots
wants to trade up
um i think that would be a really good
spot to do it
um so that is my guess corner or trade
back to the cowboys ian i'll see you in
ohio keep my seat nice and warm will you
please i heard it's supposed to rain and
be a little chilly on thursday so let's
do that i would i would confirm that
news
thanks richard take care here you go
that's ian rappaport joining us from my
chair
at the nfl draft hey you watched all the
way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here